vous avez enfreint avoir tu veux quand
je t'explose atroce je suis là pour vous
arrêter
mais note le sahara par terre ça va 13 x
traîtresse code 4 le suspect a été
appréhendé
on patrouille entre ici et newton l'un
des secteurs les plus dures de los
angeles
oui le 13 porte monnaie
surveillez la rue assurez vous qu aucun
connard ne débarquent ici et essaye de
nous défendre
ça va oui oui on cherche quoi déjà cam
afrique est pleine
en effet les autorités nous ont signalé
avoir fait une découverte macabre
lors de la plus grosse saisie de drogue
de lève toi et ton copain faut vous
calmer les cartels sévices par ici avec
des règles différentes faut point cessé
sans culé quand ils sont seuls
c'est ce qu'on va faire vous allez
perdre comme ça et je saurai m'en
souvenir
elle est où la [ __ ] de cavalerie des
crayats je suis le destin avec une
plaque un flag je protège les proie des
prédateurs
les bons des méchants
allez bonne bouche pouces nous sommes la
police
il ya un contrat sur vos benchikha vous
est blacklisté en effluves c'est normal
tout le monde veut notre peau